you are doing more projects more acting
have you already thought about what
you're going to be doing this year like
what other films are you possibly
getting ready to do
well I'm definitely going to do the
sequel to My Spy um because I know that
for sure because we start later next
month so I'm off to South Africa to do
that which I've been pushing for for a
very long time because I love the first
film it was just such it was so much fun
uh so we're going to do a sequel to that
um I'm hoping that we I have a project
in the works with Drew Pierce again sure
and we've collaborated on this film
called the cooler and it's basically
about um the life
this crazy weekend of this uh guy who's
a bouncer in Miami who was just trying
to redeem himself so it's that but it's
um
it's kind of a
it's kind of an after hours meets uncut
gems
so it's quirky and funny and suspenseful
and thrilling but also a lot of heart I
and I really insist on doing stuff
that's gotten you know hard at the core
of it is it definitely going this year
we hope so we hope so um
um Drew's uh you know he was busy on
mission impossible so he was working
with that no so now he's you know he's
got a few issues that he's dealing with
so but hopefully he'll start writing the
script uh soon